guten tag ich heiße marco hallo mein
name ist balu woher kommst du
ich komme aus italien
italien ist ein schönes land
danke woher kommst du ich komme aus sri
lanka wo liegt sri lanka in asien
sri lanka ist im süden neben indien es
ist eine insel danke für die erklärung
welche sprache spricht man in sri lanka
meine muttersprache ist tamilisch aber
man spricht in sri lanka auch
singhalesisch in italien spricht man
italienisch sprichst du noch andere
sprachen ja ich spreche auch noch
englisch
und ich kam noch ein bisschen spanisch
sprechen deutsch natürlich auch ich
wohne seit sechs jahren in der schweiz
ich wohne in glarus wo wohnst du
ich wohne in chur ich arbeite als
maschinist was arbeitest du
ich arbeite als koch bist du verheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet das ist meine
frau hasst du kinder
ich habe einen sohn
und eine tochter
und du bist du verheiratet nein ich bin
nicht verheiratet ich bin ledig ich bin
23 jahre alt wie alt bist du ich bin 35
jahre hart ich lebe seit sechs jahren in
der schweiz
wie lange liebst du schon in der schweiz
ich lebe seit zwei jahren in der schweiz
es gefällt mir sehr gut hier
im winter fahre ich snowboard
im sommer
hätte ich gern
was sind deine hobbys
ich lese gern
ich kümmere mich auch
meinen garten
ich muss zurück
riecht es freut mich die ich
kennengelernt zu haben danke gleichfalls
es war nett mit dir zu sprechen